all right so I've is ready to go so
we'll move on next morning and first of
all thank you to the organizers for
inviting me this is a wonderful place
I'm sure I'm going to enjoy the next
three months yeah
and of course I've only just arrived
so this is a great opportunity for me to
introduce my research to you so like the
previous talk this talk is also going to
be about logic and probability but there
are differences because I don't come
from the AI background I work in form of
verification in computer aided
verification so the logic is going to be
temporal logic rather than first-order
logic and the probability is not going
to be for data the probability is going
to be used in to represent the system
dynamics and also another contrast it's
not going to be busy I mean it's going
to be the frequentist interpretation but
there are similarities and the
similarities in that I also want to work
on software tools and this is the
subtitle from theory to practice there
will be a software tool which is an
extension of the prison model checker
that was developed in my group and this
talk is going to be about my new project
what we are working on and I will also
say something about where we are going
and I hope I can get to that last slide
I can also identify some gaps
perhaps for verification people okay so
of all I think it should be fairly clear
to you that there has been tremendous
progress in mobile robotics in terms of
technology I think deep learning
mentions so mobile autonomy Lee is here
and it is for real
so their robots don't just you know
clean the floor for you people are
inviting them into the homes to take
care of the elderly and of course it's
very appropriate for around here the
Google car that's a self-driving car
that has been introduced and it's not
just Google uber and Tesla are doing the
same and I wanted to start by asking the
question are we safe of course I'm
dramatizing a little bit you do not want
to see a blue screen you know when you
are driving that you know you are riding
not driving you are riding in a Google
car but in fact what they do maybe they
don't produce the blue screen but what
they do but the Tesla does is simply
hands over back to the drive of course I
say imagined of real and if you have
been following the news and the Google
car crashed into a bus but Tesla has
been in the news even more because there
has been a fatal crash of its autopilot
and it is currently being investigated
so what what do people like me want to
do well you know first of all inside
each such device each such robots are
driving car etc there is software and we
wanted to make sure that this software
is predictable and it is safe to use so
for example there will be comparing
failure and there will be environmental
uncertainty what we want to do is going
to quantify it probabilistically and
then develop methods that can express
quantitative probabilistic and other
types of quantitative properties and
bring in quantitative verification so
model checking which employs temporal
logic but in conjunction with
probability so quantitative verification
employs quantitative formal models and I
will say in a minute what that means you
can get these models you can extract
them from code you can use them at
runtime and you specify goals and
objectives in temporal logic but with
probabilistic information in them so you
can talk in addition to temporal logic
you can also talk about the
probabilistic quantifier so for example
the alert signal will be delivered with
high probability in 10 milliseconds if
you are talking about in-car
communication now the focus of my work
has been on model-based design automated
verification via model checking and more
recently also strategy synthesis so the
overview of the framework is as follows
now the idea is that we wanted to model
the Google car I mean it's a it's a
vision it's a very ambitious goal at the
moment we are modeling components so you
can have you know probabilistic failure
for example now the idea is that these
states are discrete but to link up with
the previous talk they can actually be
probability distributions probability
distributions over the states if you
have uncertainty but the probability
distributions they are represent the
dynamics so they tell me about the
probability of
from one state to another I also have a
probabilistic specification and that
probabilistic specification simply says
the probability that eventually within
time T I'm heading crash a crashing
state is small
okay small perhaps not small enough for
most of you I think we would want to
have something like ten to the minus
five ten to the minus six now if you
have a model and the specification you
put it into a probabilistic model
checker like prism you can get answers
yes this is satisfied no this is not
satisfied and you can also obtain a
strategy from a specification you can
obtain the strategy for the Google car
for going from A to B now historically
speaking probabilistic verification goes
back to the 1980s where the first
algorithms were introduced in the
context of LTL but first implementations
came later and in fact prism is a tool
that was developed around 2000 so it's
2001 it's 15 years old now but in the
last 15 years there has been a lot of
progress and the tools have matured and
the usage has increased in you know
there are probabilistic model checking
is used in in many many different areas
but the question I wanted to ask in this
talk is which modeling abstraction
should we use for may vary autonomy
there are many many probabilistic models
many of you would know about Markov
chains so I have discrete States and I
have helps discrete probability
distributions that tell me how to move
with what probability I move to the next
state this is not sufficient in many
cases so you may also want to include
decisions where there is a choice
perhaps between probability distribution
but of course that discrete discrete
States discrete probability do not
represent the real physical world so we
also need to bring in continuous
continuous real time and also continuous
space and you may want to have you know
continuous space as well as discrete
mode switching but is this really what
Mabel
autonomy demands now Mayberry autonomy
is about autonomous systems so these are
systems that continuously interact with
the environment but the environment can
of course include other cars pedestrians
as well so the environment itself is
active it is not passive because Mabel
robots are autonomous they have their
own goals and their own objectives and
these goals and objectives can conflict
with the goals and objectives of the
other agency in the environment and of
course they also take decisions
depending on you know where they are
depending on the current state so it's a
it's very natural to adopt a game
theoretic view where the player for the
Google car is the car itself and you
know the other players in their game are
cars in the oncoming traffic and you
know added also pedestrians and in fact
there are many many or currencies of
games in practice what I'm stressing
here is that I'm taking stochastic games
and putting them in the context of
modeling the dynamics of mobile robots
so what makes a game well first of all
they have to be players and you can talk
about n players and the place will take
turns or perhaps they would be come
carry
rock-paper-scissors is an example of a
concurrent game but crucially I'm going
to work with games which are stochastic
so there is also an element of
stochasticity which comes perhaps from
uncertainty but it may also come from
randomization where you use probability
intentionally there is a value payoff
for a game and of course the key
question that we study in games is does
there exist a winning strategy and if
yes can you construct it so you might
say well what does this I have to do
with the Google car well I can show you
a news clip and this is what Google
actually responded following the the car
crashing in a bus and they of course
they are realising that the issue is
more complex and for cars to actually
merge into traffic they will actually
have to explicitly negotiate negotiate
with the other players of the game so
what this lecture is about is about
putting forward stochastic multiplayer
games as a modeling abstraction for
competitive behavior in the context of
mobile autonomy with adversarial
environments and why stochasticity
because there is failure and also
because there is uncertainty autonomous
cars actually have to employ perception
modules so they have to work constantly
with sensors and these sensors are
actually going to give me probability
distributions because they are going to
be uncertain about it so I will
introduce a temporal logic with the
probabilistic quantifier for it but I
will also stress that it is not enough
to work with single objectives and try
to argue for what we call
she objectives and I will mention that
there is a tall called prison gangs 2.0
and I'll finish off with some future
challenges so what is a stochastic
multiplayer game well I have multiple
players and these players can take
decisions and the idea is that they play
against each other but probability comes
from either failures or as I've
mentioned noisy sensors or also
randomization now the games that I'm
considering here are actually very
simple games they are turn-based I don't
even consider concurrent for now they
are discrete time zero sum and complete
observation there is much much work in
game theory which has developed
techniques algorithmic techniques for
much more complex games but I'm just
shamelessly focusing on the work in my
group because of the tool the tool is
currently limited to these types of
games but they are widely studied so
I've mentioned mobile autonomy but of
course distributed coordination or
security is another example where you
have a game between a defender and an
attacker so a stochastic multiplayer
game in my case it is a turn-based game
is you can think about it like an MDP I
have finitely many discrete states but
these states are partitioned amongst a
number of players and I'm representing
them here in terms of colors so because
this is a partitioning in a game in in
the turn-based game
every state is controlled by exactly one
player so I can think about it as an MDP
with an additional structure of multi
players now what a play can do is can
choose between actions a and B but each
action is a probability distribution
explicitly representing the fact that
you can have a correct and you know a
failure the correct behavior or a
failure for example so you can also
annotate these stochastic games with
rewards or costs and I'll just mention
here an example where these rewards and
costs are simply annotations of the
states or actions and in this simplified
case they are going to be non-negative
but this is not any central restriction
now for games what I want to do is they
wants to talk about a variety of
objectives the simplest kind of
objective is I suppose probability
probabilistic reach ability what's the
probability of reaching a particular
state but the reward based objectives
include expected total reward so if you
are in a computation you want to sum up
the reward along the computation but you
can also talk about mean payoff
what's the long-run average which is the
reward divided by the number of steps or
a ratio rewards okay think about the
reward per unit time so you have a ratio
reward where you divide the reward by
the amount of time there are many many
more I'm not considering them here so I
have a game I have a turn-based
stochastic multiplayer game where I have
n players to represent the behavior ok
the dynamics of that game I will start
in the initial State
I will unfold it into the set of all the
possible infinite computations where
each computation is an alternating
sequence of states and the actions ok
the action which is the choice that has
been made now as strategy and sometimes
I'll also talk about an adversary
perhaps but a strategy is simply a
mapping which takes a history that is a
finite computation which finishes with a
state of some player and then it returns
a probability distribution over the
decisions this of course includes as
direct distributions also the
deterministic choices so I can talk
about strategies being deterministic or
randomized I can talk about memoryless
strategies if they are history
insensitive I can also talk about finite
memory or infinite memory strategies the
strategy profile if you have n players
is a vector of n strategies one for each
player now for a strategy profile once
you fix the strategy profile and
stochastic turn-based game you can
derive a Markov chain it will be an
infinite state Markov chain with it
states of that chain are going to be
simply the finite histories and we can
then derive a probability measure
standard probability measure over that
and it allows us to reason about the
probability of events and it also allows
us to reason about expected rewards
because the samples in my probability
space are infinite computations I can
define a random variable which gives me
the reward for each sample and take the
standard expectation for the probability
measure but I also need
- right than the properties and for this
I need a property specification language
and I'm resorting to temporal logic and
this temporal logic our phe L stands for
reward probabilistic alternating
temporal logic and it's a hybrid it's a
hybrid of a TL because it has the
coalition operator of a TL but on top of
that has the probabilistic operator like
the one that I showed you which is from
PCT and probabilistic version of the
computation free logic and it also has a
reward operator so the probabilistic
operator computes the probability
compares it to the band and the reward
operator computes the expectation and
compares it to the Balint now with this
I can express properties for example
that players one and two in a coalition
have a strategy to ensure that the
probability of an error occurring within
ten steps is less than point one
regardless of the strategies of other
players and I can then formally write
down the language were alike in PCT L I
have is a state formula and it expresses
the coalition and I can talk about the
probabilistic operate reward and ratio
rewards
now read the reward operator takes a
formula which either expresses long-run
average or the total cumulative total
reward so I can now talk about well
players in coalition C have a collective
strategy to ensure that the game reaches
an end state almost surely regardless of
the strategies of other players now I
wanted to have
and model checking algorithm for that I
also can represent the reward properties
so the semantics the semantics for most
operators is standard so here I just
want to tell you what the semantics for
the P and the R operator is like since I
have introduced the concept of a
coalition I'm interested in strategies
for the coalition against strategies of
everybody else so I can simply reduce a
multiplayer game to a two-player game
where play 1 is the coalition and player
2 is everybody else and then I can say
that this property is true for some
coalition see if in the coalition game
there exists a strategy for the
coalition such that for all strategies
of everybody else I win the coalition
winners okay so this is a very natural
interpretation and just to see whether
you are awake this is an example of of a
stochastic multiplayer game and the
first question is does that player have
a strategy to get to the jackpot with
probability 1/4 yes
right what about probability at least
1/3
no because it can be prevented from
doing so by the other players but of
course the yellow player can enter in
the into a coalition with either the
blue or the green player and then it can
increase okay so the reward is then for
a coalition not for an individual so
that's the idea and for the stochastic
multiplayer games we studied through
fundamental problems one is the
verification problem which is defined as
the existence of a strategy for the
coalition which is winning against any
adversary notice that this is rather
different from for example working with
MDPs which have a universal
interpretation for all you know
strategies you want to obtain some
reward but here you have to exist this
strategy now there is also the synthesis
problem assuming such a strategy exists
can you find one so I want to go from A
to B minimizing the cost can you find me
a strategy now it turns out that both
players we've reduced the two player
games they have optimal strategies and
for the logic fragment without step
bounded memoryless deterministic
strategies suffice and I can also
construct the strategies I employ a
value iteration so this is actually
exactly as it was done by an condom for
what she called simple stochastic games
but aa
single single objectives enough
and the point I'm trying to make here is
know so if you think about the Google
car
there is always an overriding objective
which is safety we don't want any
crashes we don't want to hit an oncoming
car but there will also be other
objectives and you would want these
objectives to be satisfied
simultaneously so instead of considering
just single objectives I want to allow
the possibility of multi objectives or
sometimes also called multi-dimensional
and I'm going to restrict just two
conjunctions okay so the idea is that I
have two such objectives but each comes
with a different probability of three or
e-world
bound and I want to meet both these at
the same time so and a strategy which
will meet the reward the bounds for each
component now for many applications
conjunctions are enough but if you want
to have this kind of reasoning for
assume guarantee then you need to go and
you will need boolean combinations so
the tool is not restricted to
conjunctions I'm just simplifying I'm
also simplifying the presentation by
showing you an example of a Markov
decision process rather than a game and
in this Markov decision process I have a
conjunction of properties I want to
reach D with probability at least point
two and I wanted to reach E with rubbish
point six I have three actions but
notice that deterministic strategies are
not enough because the deterministic
strategies are represented here okay but
they do not meet both bands
simultaneously in fact what I have to
work with is randomized strategies and
that's already the case for mdps so I
have to work with randomized trial
oh geez and this strategy is one that
meets these now the shaded area
represents all randomized strategies and
the dark blue is the Pareto front or the
Pareto curve which gives me the optimal
point so these are pairs of values where
you cannot improve one without
decreasing the value of the other and
with this approach what I can do is take
and then explore the trade-offs so
whichever point you choose here
corresponds to a different weight of the
combination of these two deterministic
strategies and this is perhaps something
that the designer may want to choose now
this was for mgp's for mdps optimal
strategies exist but random my
strategies may be needed the situation
for stochastic games is much more
complex because even optimal strategies
may not exist and I may need infinite
memory so I have to work with restricted
games and I also work with the casting
memory update representation which is a
more succinct representation if you are
interested in this I can explain this in
in the break it has the same power as
the notion of the strategies that I've
given you but it is more succinctly in
particular it's enough to work with
finite ones which is not enough for the
other ones so now I'm showing you an
example of a Pareto set which you can
obtain from the tool and this is also a
snapshot you know from the tool which
can work with any objectives in general
and it will support slicing projections
and slicing so 2d but what we also
support is compositional strategy
synthesis that is not compositional
verification but compositional strategy
synthesis this is because of course this
state space explosion is a huge problem
and if I have a game which is built from
a number of components then I have the
exponential state space explosion and
these games very quickly become too much
for the poor tool to cope so the idea is
to introduce assume guarantee reasoning
where if you have two games Game one and
game 2
if one guarantees Phi a and the other
one guarantees Phi B but under the
assumption that Phi a is satisfied then
you can deduce this global property for
the parallel composition of the game
which you do not actually have to
construct you do not have to construct
this is not a straightforward operator
for games just think about how you'd
combine two local states when you have
different players so this is not a
straightforward thing and something that
has not been studied much in in for
example in concurrency theory developing
these types of operators so what we can
do with with the lithium guarantee rules
is we can construct strategies for the
composition for the global system by
composing local strategies this is at a
cost of expressiveness
I will not be able to obtain every
strategy but it gives me so it gives me
an under approximation of the parrot
offset but the improves the speed of
analysis and this is what you know the
kind this kind of reasoning would do so
there is soul there is the the
which is called prism games and it is an
extension of prism currently it is
explicit state but there is working
progress on developing a symbolic in
implementation which is much quicker in
terms of the model construction and
there have been several case studies so
even though I showed you games which
only discrete state discrete time and
discrete probabilities we have also
considered games which you obtained from
stochastic hybrid systems but you have
to do it by discretizing so so far what
I hope I have shown you is that in order
to model this competitive and
cooperative behavior as you know on the
road Google cars or collaboration
between robotic assistance and and
humans and I have also mentioned that
there is a tool to support it but the
final question I wanted to ask is is
this going to be sufficient i've already
argued that we should switch away from
MDPs
towards stochastic games that's a huge
complexity but do can we really just
work with games and again if you are
following the news it is becoming very
clear now that games on their own will
not suffice now if a human has to
negotiate something or another car has
to negotiate something with a Google car
they need very complex multimodal
communication and that something at
robotics the robotics community is
looking at but we also need to consider
the cognitive reasoning processes that
the human goes through because we have
to make the east cars more like you
so you need to introduce cognitive
architecture there are also social norms
trust the Tesla car crush has been
described as the case of over trust so a
provocative question can we do
quantitative verification for trust
morality is another one if you are
letting a robotic assistant into a
elderly care home how do you make sure
that you know these behave ethically so
it's not that simple
but another gap that I wanted to mention
and here I'm very grateful to my
collaborators from the Oxford robotics
Institute that's a joint project that we
have and I'm very grateful for
introducing these great problems for me
to study perception software perceptions
software perception software relies on
machine learning deep learning for
example in this is a picture that I am
showing you this is the technology that
was developed at Oxford and it builds a
point cloud it uses lider
and the first learns a map by driving a
car around it and then the idea is that
if it if the car drives itself it has
access to the map but also in real time
needs to be able to tell the difference
between the car a motorbike or a
pedestrian okay and for this they are
using machine learning not here deep
learning but they're working on deep
learning and developing an end-to-end
which is a complete machine learning
solution no logic now in of course there
are many things that can go wrong in
perception software you can have a sense
of failure but you can also have an
object detection failure and machine
learning software is not it is not very
clear how it works and also you know for
us verification people were obsessed
about guarantees but machine learning
algorithm
don't provide any hard guarantees so
this is a topic that pain tend to study
and perhaps tackle the issue of doing
formal verification for these kinds of
modules so this brings me to the
conclusion and you know so far have
introduced stochastic multiplayer game
as a modeling abstraction for mobile
robotics Maybell autonomy but the work
so far has focused on properties like
safety efficiency both in a single and
multi objective case but there are many
things that we have not even started to
tackle so for example partial
observability that's not handled by the
tool I've mentioned perception software
but also since we are talking about
games the logic that I've mentioned
actually gives you Nash equilibria but
it doesn't give you all the interesting
Nash equilibria so some combination with
which would give you the right Nash
equilibria is interesting in the
combination with mechanism design and
the observation is that even building on
top of these games we need to extend
them with cognitive reasoning and
perhaps you know even social aspects
human-like trust and the big question
for me is can we develop quantitative
verification and since synthesis
techniques what synthesis think of the
counter strategy so I wanted to avoid
you know some flow I may want to develop
a strategy yeah ask the tool to to give
me a strategy to avoid a crash so that's
it and I wanted to acknowledge my
collaborators too many mister I didn't
put all the names and the funding thank
you
you said that the you everything
frequentist and everything
Oh
okay I mean so I wasn't telling I mean
in this in the work behind prison all is
based on the frequentist interpretation
but actually we are we are developing
something where we do take the Bayesian
approach as well so if I can give you an
example I think appealing to this I need
a prior and I worked with States which
are probability distributions these
probability distributions can for
example be GPS data there is a data type
now developed called uncertainty which
represents these distributions and yes
then starting from the prior I can do
inference and then I mean I have to say
that my tool is incredibly so compared
to I think would be heard about in the
in the first talk so if we can learn and
I adopt some techniques from AI then we
haven't tried them CMC yes yeah and well
and I mean also in the way that the
probability measure is defined just
define based on the frequencies what you
mean the probability of getting
somewhere else but I can redefine it I
can still define a model for the
dynamics I just need to change the
notion of the state and transitions
between the states one more quick one
it seemed like this almost a direct
contradiction between a model checking
approach and dealing with probabilities
because if you're assuming everything's
known yeah yeah no I guess that is
that's right that's is a very good point
I mean what's logic logic is about zero
and one true and false yes so in this
case I get true and false by computing
the probability and comparing it to the
threshold so that's my true and false
but I can also take a quantitative
interpretation I can simply ask the tool
to give me the probability or the
expectation and in fact this is this was
an afterthought but people this is
something that we've added to the tool
because people wanted to use it that way
all right let's make market one more
time I'll be in the break now check the
screens for the updated schedule